living with a chronic disease like
cystic fibrosis is
a daily battle and even more difficult
during a pandemic
lauren milaski fierce is from las vegas
she has cf
she's not only defying the odds but
inspiring others along the way
we spoke with her about her journey
designer
fashion blogger author and mother lauren
malaski fierce
has accomplished a lot the past 37 years
and much more than doctors expected they
did not expect me to live much beyond
four or five lauren was diagnosed with
cystic fibrosis at just two days old
it's a chronic disease that affects your
lungs and digestive systems
she's developed more problems over the
years but her world completely changed
last summer
when one of her lungs collapsed talking
was
too much and laughing i couldn't laugh
imagine
breathing through a straw and that's it
24 7. her lungs were functioning at less
than
17 percent this was happening as coven
19
surged across the country because of
restrictions
her husband was allowed to stay with her
in the hospital
but she could only see her two children
once a week
for an hour at a time it was a very very
dark time
after a year on the wait list and living
in the hospital for four
long months lauren finally got the call
there was a match
she received a double lung transplant
this past october
very very grateful for all that i've
been given
and this you know second chance writing
has always been an outlet for lauren
she started a fashion blog years ago and
recently wrote a book called the sky
cracked open
it's a series of poems mostly written
for her kids
who she says are her motivation for
years my son
would use all of his wishes whether it
was like a birthday candle
or an eyelash or whatever for his mom to
get new lungs
those wishes came true lauren is still
quarantining at home with her family
but doing much better as dark as it is
there's always light and there's always
something to
be grateful for she is such an
inspiration this is a copy of her book
we were just talking about it's really
cute
made by the way it is cystic fibrosis
awareness month and lauren
has become an advocate for cystic
fibrosis and
john she has a second book now in the
works so
it's so good to see that she got that
and it was successful and she's doing
better
quite a prolific writer good stuff yeah
great story and fantastic does she
see that she is recovering all right